طيب اذا كانت انت ذكرتك
اللغويه وذاكرتك البصريه هي ذاكره الفتها
البيئه والفها الموروث
والفها يعني المكان اللي انت
عشت فيه ونشات كيف بتقدر كيف تقدر تذهب
الى نص بغير لغه لتبني على مناخات لتبني
عليه مناخات بصريه
ربما الحرف العربي
بيحفز لك المخيلي اكثر لللص الفرنسي
تجد صعوبه او ربما وهذا يمكن ابحار في
مكان خطر شوي يعني المخاطره جزء من النجات
يعني
ومخاطره مثلا ابعد اشتغلت من اشهر قليله
معرض بالسويد
اسمه جمرات الثلج المعرض كله مستوحى من
الشارع السويدي وهنا نقطه المترجم المترجم
يعني انت تذهب يعني تاخذ من المعنى مش من
وهي نقطه مهمه جدا اللغه السويديه هي لغه
ذات جرس صوتي جميل
وذات تعبير صوتي وليس تعبير باللغه اللغه
ليست دقيقه مثل الالمانيه والفرنسيه لكن
هي كصوت هي لغه تعبيريه تحت وصرفه وتحتمل
الايقاعات وعلاقات الاحرف ببعضها علاقات
تستند الى موسيقى معينه جميله فعملت الى
تحويله لان الحرف العربي يمتلك هذا
المخزون الموازي من الاشكال بالحرف العربي
عندي قدره لا محدوده او غير
بتوليد الاشكال والصيغه الحرفيه فعملت نوع
من المقابله بين لغه كصوت
وبمعنى حيدت اللغه المكتوبه
والمنجز الحرفي اللي اشتغل عليه طبعا
اللغه العربيه اظن فيها 13 مليون كلمه
يمكن يوجد قاموس بالحرف اوسع من اللغه